[Música]
los invito a todos
aquí siendo los ojos conmigo
no respiren
no respiren no respiren
no retiren
abre los ojos
y 28 médicos lo están mirando con cara
de preocupación con cara de no saber qué
les está pasando esa persona
tiene un fuerte dolor en el pecho una
presión acá fuerte
siendo la sensación fría que le sube por
este brazo
en el suelo que tienen conectado acá
eso me pasó en julio de este año el 18
de julio
en 2015 la vida me llevó a emprender
yo tenía todo planificado que salía de
la facultad que iba a hacer tal cosa y
hace tal otra
pero el mismo médico no
por otro lado
en aquel momento tenía mi abuela con
alzheimer y yo no podía comunicarse no
podía hablar
así que fue que junto con héctor mi
hermano
decidimos crear otro proyecto que es el
primer sistema inteligente de
comunicación para personas con
discapacidad
personas con parálisis cerebral autismo
síndrome dan más fácil hoy pueden
comunicarse hay más de 40 mil personas
40 mil personas es un estadio el estadio
kempes lleno de personas que hoy se
están pudiendo comunicar con sus padres
los padres que hay acá imagínense la
primera vez que escucharon la palabra su
hijo ya lo dijo que están acá imagínense
que tiene su padre internado y lo pueden
volver a escuchar
en 2016 ya un poco pasado esto que
estábamos creando recibimos un mail de
una incubadora de una seriedad ahora de
empresas que no había seleccionado sólo
seis emprendimiento de todo el mundo
tuvieron la posibilidad de ir a dubai a
pasar por este proceso de celebración
que lo que significaba plata para eso lo
que estamos quieren hacer significaba
mentores significa estar con gente que
yo estoy casi seguro que hoy no les voy
a poder volver a tener cent al frente
mío para contarlo en modelo de negocio
para recibir feedback para contar
absolutamente lo que sea para aprender
y significaba también irse seis meses a
vivir a dubai salimos desde córdoba con
mi hermano con la valijita a vivir allá
les puedo asegurar que aprendimos un
montón de cosas y como les dije era vida
muerte sabíamos que estábamos en un
momento único de la empresa que tenemos
que dejar todo que tenemos que ser todos
a los 4 meses de haber estado ahí en esa
rutina de iniciada inicia ferviente cosa
que es el emprendedorismo que tiene
muchas palabras en inglés que tiene
mucho estrés que tiene muchas reuniones
que tiene cosas que te las dice un de
hacer hoy pero tras bien entregar
y fuimos entrando en eso vuelvo a
empezar a ver que gente que tiene éxito
en lo que emprender vive eso vive esa
rutina o por lo menos lo que muestra
para afuera
pero eso está mal es tóxico si lo puedes
lo puedes ir personalmente
estamos en el metro volviendo un día
como un jueves
estamos volviendo en el metro a casa de
la oficina
y empiezo a ver cosas que no había visto
antes empiezo a ver veo un edificio
acabé unas palmeras a cada vez cosas que
no había visto entonces un pagaré para
el otro lado del metro o me confundí de
estación o lo que sea
pasaba que estábamos volviendo de día al
departamento
durante cuatro meses tuvimos una rutina
excesivamente intensa desayunábamos
temprano tipo seis de la mañana salíamos
de noche volvíamos a la oficina teníamos
reuniones con inversores teníamos
reuniones con otros colegas teníamos
reuniones con mentores y cuando
volvíamos ya era de noche
entonces el el haber podido volver en
otro horario de la oficina fue una
elección que hasta el día de hoy la
estoy tratando de aprender y de llevar
adelante
porque porque me hizo dar cuenta de la
cantidad de cosas que estábamos haciendo
mal si no estamos emprendiendo estábamos
haciendo lo que nos teníamos cuidado a
nosotros mismos
personalmente creo que las herramientas
están dadas hoy para que cualquiera de
acá porque no tengo absolutamente nada
en especial nada más que tener gana y
voluntad de acción la herramienta están
dadas para que cualquiera de acá pueda
conseguir financiamiento crear un equipo
y crear algo que genere impacto que para
nosotros es lo más importante
la herramienta están dadas pero se está
incentivando desde toda esta cultura
emprendedora a tener un ritmo a tener un
nivel de estrés que es tóxico que no
está bueno
ahí me permite robar una frase que
siempre me dice una madre desde hace ese
tiempo la que este cuerpo esto lo que
somos lo que somos nosotros y nuestra
alma nuestro espíritu nos dura todo el
viaje nos dura toda la vida entonces
tengo que saber cuidarlo tenemos que
protegerlo
para mí la pregunta está en que cada uno
de ustedes decidan emprender o si están
trabajando si deciden hacer algo como lo
estamos haciendo nosotros sepan ponerse
los límites sepan hasta dónde dar cada
uno por qué porque si no se hace se
corre un riesgo muy grande y se paga
excesivamente caro a nivel personal a
nivel emocional y económico también
durante estos últimos años de mi vida de
trabajo sinceramente tuve la posibilidad
de hacer todo lo que quise fue recorrer
el mundo
puedes juntarme con un site en dubai
puede hablar de igual a igual con el
presidente
una de las cosas más importantes y fue
cambiarle la vida a más de 40.000
personas
y creo que la más importante que puede
llegar a hacer fue ver la otra cara de
lo que emprender
empecemos por cuidar de nosotros mismos
porque nuestra alma y aquí tenemos al
lado muchas gracias
[Aplausos]